we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i am going
to play this voicemail for you with a
total neutrality in the sense that i am
not going to prejudge for you whether
this is a serious voicemail or it is
someone who's trolling me i have an
opinion okay let's take a listen to it
together hi there david you've must i
don't understand why you think trumps is
a KKK member the democrats started the
KKK hillary clinton love robert byrd
looked him up he was a Grand Wizard of
the KKK where is your history I don't
think you do any kind of like studying
how did you do in school and you don't
even know your history
Trump is take you down pedos big time
what do you think the Q movement is all
about pedophilia who do you think's
running the government and the world a
bunch of pet O's look up George Nader
who was just finally busted for screwing
a 11 year old boy or something a 14 year
old it was with him from Europe he
screws little babies they have it on his
phone that they caught him with Trump
was behind that also Epstein who do you
think is taken down Epstein Trump
he hates Epstein II yeah so listen it
goes on for like two more minutes do you
think that is real genuine or do you
think it is not I'll now give you my
opinion I believe that that is
completely genuine that in looking at
the caller ID and the call history of
that individual
they have slowly become whackier and
whackier and I believe that that is not
a parody I know that for some of you
it's hard to believe that that's a real
person that exists in the world that is
my best assessment based on everything I
know if you are shocked by that then
maybe you're not paying attention
because that is what we are up against
right now pedos QQ and on conspiracies I
you know why did you say Trump is in the
KKK I never did I mean it is it is
little this is someone whose brain has
has rotted out this is the equivalent of
if you just have candy candy candy
everyday and sugar sodas and you never
brush your teeth and then four years
later you wake up
and you know what what's going on with
your teeth the equivalent has happened
from putting the the whatever is
analogous informational e to sugar sodas
and sugar candy in your brain is what
has happened to this caller and I
believe it is 100% real send me your
thoughts if you disagree great bonus
show for you today
become a member become a patron I'll
speak to you then